23 pending challenges 420 bond cloud is
subbing there's only one thing to do now
let's take another random challenge and
let's play the bond cloud don't play
queen h5 don't play queen h5 maybe I
shouldn't pretty Mookie knee 7 ok Keeney
7 I'm playing the blunt cloud because
420 bond cloud just subscribed I have to
show some love so the subscribers even
if it's in a dubious manner oh this is
gonna be a painful position to play by
the way if I play queen h5 and I did pre
move King g7 it's made of 1
okay so d4 at least he's not like
winning a free pawn I think I'll just
take and I think the goal with this
opening like John Bartholomew put out a
video like really instructive video I
think about last week explaining the
nuances of the bond cloud and I think
the goal is to just activate the king
like control the center and now I'm also
unleashing the bishop and like okay the
knight could go to f6 but when the Kings
on f6 that controls a lot of squares on
the fifth rank when the Knights on f6
doesn't control any of these squares
also e8 is available for my queen maybe
attack that's a good move yeah he saw my
plan of century can Center control if I
move here I got mated if I move here I
probably end up getting me that I have
to move back
yeah sometimes plans don't work in chess
or in life this this is rated oh man
okay well at least I'm playing with some
purpose I think I'm gonna play f6 next
just restrict the bishop from coming
here cuz i play Knight f6 is Bishop g5
which is annoying yeah and that way
there's no Queen takes f7 there's a
knight or knife half 598 and thence like
the starting position with like one pawn
move and one missing pawn can't complain
equal material I have some plan of
forking the Queen and the bishop
what's BM blonde cloud master you have
to win a certain number of games in the
blonde cloud to be declared upon cloud
master wait the John Bartholomew video
is an April Fool's joke
it seems so serious
let's play c6 timing to push ponds at
some point blacks should probably
develop another idea with c6 is just to
maneuver the king to c7 what is this
called the palace some sort of Palace
was John Bartholomew saying the palace
on the Eastern Front okay let's play b5
and attack the bishop if it takes I
can't take with Kings I'd probably have
to take with mice Oh the Winter Palace
people in the chat knows what knows
what's up he's checking me in to hang
out five what
okay I have a pawn chain yeah I'd really
like to take with King but have to take
with Knights and now there's some plan
of just walking the King up and then
deck is it's important like in chess for
your king to get exercise you want it to
be in shape so it can defend itself
yeah Queen h5 was always met with Knight
takes that's a good move I mean I have
two legal moves here there's this and
exists in King g6 now I'm controlling
more center squares whoa it's bits from
where's my bento a thousand bits
I have only one legal move there's a
rule in chess if you have only one leg
legal move you shouldn't think you
should just play it
can you mate by moving your king yes but
only if it's like discovered checkmate
okay so I have my Winter Palace I'm
attacking a bishop this isn't bad like
my King is honestly more safe than
whites King and White's King hasn't even
gotten like any exercise I'm ready to
play Queen e8
Bishop b4 just started on lining things
with the opponent's king the ship before
would maybe sack upon but sometimes
piece play is more valuable than pawns
the idea is to play Nike for and attack
things explained I need oh wait 94
denied takes you for and at Bishop takes
c3 there's 96 check so let's play d5
discovered attack getting ready to
devolve more things whoa that's a tricky
move because still if I take here and
there's 96 I take here then this happens
so I think the appropriate thing to do
is set up the board for the next game
like night and then my King has to come
back mmm it's hard to move the pawns
backwards though and I could promote
them but then they no longer pawns wait
this is a free night I'm up at night and
I've developed the plan now is probably
just to go back like my hunger is
satisfied but there's actually multiple
plans in this position let's take
another Bishop if white takes my queen I
take back and I have an open file
yeah Queen takes g7 this is kind of a
double attack thankfully my Knights
defend each other these are called sir
superfluous Knights sometimes they're
awkward and other times they're very
stable
what's accounts this is a difficult math
problem I'm down the Queen but I have a
rook a knight and a bishop
for Queen and porn let's play B for
attacking lights actually this is funny
the knight doesn't have too many safe
squares that moves here here good things
happen for me after 98 - it's just kind
of sad I could play a cure it's always
nice to align your rooks with your
ponens Queen and King simultaneously and
there's some tricks like if this and I
do this this and then this this is so
much fun
such a great opening it's like mainly
opening preparation with a little bit of
tactics it's like a cake like mainly
cake with a little bit of frosting now
I'm attacking stuff like a look at these
pieces such valiant defenders well I'm
threatening made in one I was really
hoping to like exercise my Keaney more
but I guess I've had enough Rock g1 do I
take it I take the pot I take the rook
let's take the rook and then take the
pawn and then go in for the kill
I can't use these minor pieces I'm
attacking the Queen I have ideas of this
and this life is so good I have to do my
laundry it's almost midnight
no people there's multiple machines but
should still not hold anyone up okay
let's play rook f8 first check and it's
it was beautiful
such teamwork also the King okay yeah I
think the bond cloud is an opening that
will never be destroyed
yeah I think that will be you too worthy
because there's not enough pawn clock
videos on YouTube so for the YouTube
audience who's watching in the future
you can smash that subscribe button
leave a comment below and I'll see you
in the next video